from you guys inside this is a beautiful  message from trunks that i saw on his  instagram story actually one brother  sent it to me watched inshallah oh here  we go oh no  oh guys watch this video before this guy  comes quickly  quickly guys quickly you want to say hi  to  hi say hi to bd  hey yo what's going in it  don't watch this crappy video  what chunks a reminder  what chunks a reminder  ramadan is over does not mean that islam  is over  inshallah you managed to keep up the  good deeds and the good  habits that you picked up through  ramadan even after if you did not used  to pray before ramadan and you started  praying in ramadan then please do not  stop praying after ramadan  if you used to go to the masjid make  sure you can go to the masjid if you  read the quran ramadan make sure you  read the quran after ramadan  may allah bless your eat eat mubarak